This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. You can take a horse to water, but you can't make him drink. It's an old saying, but it captures a fundamental truth about human nature. How often have you come by people who fail to seize the opportunities in front of them, who decline to make the most of the privileges they've been given? If you're a parent or a teacher, you may have sometimes felt like saying to a kid, I can't make you want it. If you're a manager, perhaps you've told an employee, there's a ladder over here, but you have to be the one to climb it.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。你可以把马牵到水边，但你不能强迫它喝水。这是一句老话，但它揭示了关于人性的一个基本真理。你遇到过多少人，他们未能抓住眼前的机会，拒绝充分利用他们所拥有的特权？如果你是父母或老师，你可能有时会想对孩子说：“我无法让你产生渴望。”如果你是经理，也许你曾对员工说：“梯子就在这里，但你必须自己去爬。”
Sometimes the thing that needs to be seized is not an opportunity, but a lifeline. Do you know people stuck in bad situations, unhappy marriages, dead-end jobs, soul-crushing living conditions, who seem unwilling to escape even when the chance presents itself? Does that describe you? Today on the show and in a follow-up episode next week, why do some people act on the possibilities before them while others believe that nothing they do can make a difference? How to discover or rediscover your ability to change things for the better
有时需要抓住的不是机会，而是一根救命稻草。你是否认识一些陷入困境的人——不幸的婚姻、死胡同般的工作、令人窒息的生活环境——即使机会摆在面前，他们似乎也不愿逃离？这是否描述了你？今天在节目中，以及下周的后续剧集中，我们将探讨：为什么有些人会根据眼前的可能性采取行动，而另一些人却认为他们所做的一切都无法改变现状？如何发现或重新发现你改变现状的能力？
this week on Hidden Brain. Every day, life presents us with small moments of possibility, a conversation that could change the course of a career, a relationship that could be repaired, a job posting that could become the start of something new. Some people step toward those moments almost instinctively. Others turn away without even trying. Today, we explore the hidden psychological forces
本周《隐藏的大脑》。每一天，生活都会向我们展示微小的可能性时刻：一次可能改变职业生涯的谈话，一段可以修复的关系，一个可能成为新事物开端的招聘启事。有些人几乎是本能地走向这些时刻。另一些人甚至不去尝试就转身离开。今天，我们探索隐藏的心理力量，
that determine which path we take and why the stories we tell about ourselves can become self-fulfilling. At the University of Pennsylvania, psychologist Martin Seligman has spent many years studying these questions. Marty Seligman, welcome to Hidden. brain. Thank you, Shankar. I'm happy to be here. Marty, I want to take you back to what might be your
这些力量决定了我们选择哪条道路，以及为什么我们讲述的关于自己的故事会成为自我实现的预言。在宾夕法尼亚大学，心理学家马丁·塞利格曼花了很多年研究这些问题。马蒂·塞利格曼，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你，尚卡尔。很高兴来到这里。马蒂，我想带你回到你可能最早的记忆中。
earliest memory. Tell me the story about a time when you saw your mother crying. I'm two and a half years old, and I think this really is my first memory. And I hear these heartbroken sobs and guests coming from the next room and I run in to see my mother and there she is sitting on the second step of the stairs to the upstairs with her head in her hands and she's sobbing. Many years later, I tried to figure out what was really going on. It would have been mid-early early 1945. I think the concentration camps had opened. And all of my mother's Hungarian relatives, her family that she abandoned in Hungary or murder. But something happened to me then, Shakra, that actually fits with the hidden brain. And that is when I look at the photos of me, I'm a smiley hair down to my shoulders,
告诉我你看到母亲哭泣的那次经历。我当时两岁半，我想这确实是我最早的记忆。我听到隔壁房间传来心碎的啜泣声和喘息声，我跑进去看我的母亲，她正坐在通往楼上的楼梯的第二级台阶上，双手抱头，正在啜泣。多年后，我试图弄清楚当时到底发生了什么。那应该是1945年初。我想集中营已经开放了。我母亲所有的匈牙利亲戚，她留在匈牙利或被谋杀的家人。但那时发生在我身上的一件事，尚卡尔，实际上与“隐藏的大脑”相吻合。那就是当我看着我的照片时，我是一个头发垂到肩膀、爱笑的孩子，
a bullion kid up until about age three. And then when I look at my photos up to my teenage and beyond, I'm tight-lipped, I'm unsmiling, I'm looking thoughtful. And when I look at my really early photographs of a smiley, a bullion kid, I don't recognize myself. Marty, I want to skip forward to another experience a few years later when you were 13. Your dad was driving you in the car, and he shared something with you that was very disturbing. Describe for me what happened.
直到大约三岁。然后当我看着我青少年时期及以后的照片时，我紧闭双唇，不苟言笑，看起来若有所思。当我看着我那些非常早期的照片，那个爱笑的孩子时，我认不出自己了。马蒂，我想跳到几年后你13岁时的另一次经历。你父亲开车带你时，他和你分享了一些非常令人不安的事情。描述一下发生了什么。
It's now 1955. I'm 13 years old, and I go to my second day of playing golf with my friend Bob Kaiser, And when my father drops us off of the golf course, he says, I can't feel my left arm. And that scared me. And it scared Bob also. I slept overnight at my best friend Jeff Albert's house. And I had this dreadful feeling that something was wrong. And I walked home probably nine in the morning the next day.
那是1955年。我13岁，我第二次去和朋友鲍勃·凯撒打高尔夫球。当我父亲把我们送到高尔夫球场时，他说：“我感觉不到我的左臂了。”这吓坏了我。也吓坏了鲍勃。我在我最好的朋友杰夫·阿尔伯特家过夜。我有一种可怕的感觉，觉得出事了。第二天早上九点左右，我走回家。
And there was my father being dragged out on a stretcher into an ambulance. And he had had a small stroke. And then within a couple of days, Shanker, my mother said my father had had massive strokes. And in the next couple of months, I visited my father, reluctantly. I was really afraid of this helplessness that I saw. And my father was paralyzed. He could speak. And he basically said, I'm helpless. I don't want to die. I love you and your sister and your mother. And I think this is the major experience of my childhood. I'm wondering, Marie, if you can spend a minute talking about the helplessness that you had seen in your mother when she was crying, the helplessness that you saw in your father when he told you that he was afraid of dying, how did that make you feel?
我父亲正被抬上担架送进救护车。他中风了。几天之内，尚卡尔，我母亲说我父亲中风很严重。在接下来的几个月里，我不情愿地去看望我父亲。我真的很害怕我所看到的这种无助感。我父亲瘫痪了。他能说话。他基本上说：“我很无助。我不想死。我爱你、你姐姐和你母亲。”我认为这是我童年时期最重大的经历。马蒂，我想知道你能不能花点时间谈谈你在母亲哭泣时看到的无助，以及你在父亲告诉你他害怕死亡时看到的无助，那让你感觉如何？
It's hard for me to remember, Shanker. I know my response was avoidance, not to visit my father, not to see more of it. But very interestingly, when I got to college, I found myself wearing black all the time and thinking all the time about death. I think those were the, if you will, the hidden brain consequences of whatever happened when I visited my father. Our experiences teach us lessons about the world. They also teach us lessons about ourselves, whether it's worth taking a risk,
这对我来说很难回忆，尚卡尔。我知道我的反应是逃避，不去探望父亲，不去面对更多。但非常有趣的是，当我上大学时，我发现自己总是穿着黑色的衣服，总是想着死亡。我想，无论我探望父亲时发生了什么，这些都是“隐藏的大脑”带来的后果。我们的经历教会我们关于世界的教训。它们也教会我们关于自己的教训，比如是否值得冒险，
whether setbacks are temporary, and whether our actions can shape what happens next. Those lessons can be remarkably powerful. When we come back, Mardi steps into a psych lab and starts to understand the true horror of helplessness. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
挫折是否是暂时的，以及我们的行动能否塑造接下来发生的事情。这些教训可能非常强大。回来后，马蒂将走进心理实验室，开始了解无助感的真正恐怖。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
All of us carry around a private explanation. for why things happen. When something goes wrong, we ask ourselves, was this just bad luck? Is it going to last? Does it say something about who I am? We usually don't notice ourselves asking these questions, but the answers can quietly shape the course of our lives.
我们每个人都随身携带一套关于事情为何发生的私人解释。当事情出错时，我们会问自己：这只是运气不好吗？这种情况会持续下去吗？这是否说明了我是一个什么样的人？我们通常不会注意到自己在问这些问题，但答案却能悄悄地塑造我们人生的轨迹。
Martin Seligman is a psychologist at the University of Pennsylvania who studies the science of human flourishing. Marty, you told me about some personal encounters with hopelessness and helplessness that you had as a teenager. A few years later, as a 21-year-old entering graduate school in psychology, you had the opportunity to explore these same themes in a research context. Paint a picture for me of what you saw when you first entered the psychologist Richard Solomon's lab.
马丁·塞利格曼是宾夕法尼亚大学的一位心理学家，研究人类繁荣的科学。马蒂，你告诉过我你青少年时期遇到的一些关于绝望和无助的个人经历。几年后，作为一名21岁进入心理学研究生院的学生，你有机会在研究背景下探索这些相同的主题。请为我描绘一下你第一次走进心理学家理查德·所罗门实验室时所看到的景象。
What was he working on, and what did you see? Well, they were doing experiments that I actually felt were horrified. I'm a dog lover, and psychologists were working with dogs at the time and giving them mild to moderate electric shock. So these were very difficult experiments for me to participate in, but there was something very puzzling going on, and that is the primary puzzle that animal learning psychologists were working on was Pavlovian conditioning. A dog or a rat or a part, person gets a tone followed by a shock, and then the tone comes to elicit fear.
他在研究什么，你看到了什么？嗯，他们正在进行的实验让我感到非常恐惧。我是一个爱狗人士，当时的心理学家正在用狗做实验，给它们施加轻度到中度的电击。所以这些实验对我来说很难参与，但发生了一些非常令人困惑的事情，那就是动物学习心理学家正在研究的主要难题是巴甫洛夫条件反射。狗、老鼠或人听到一个音调，随后受到电击，然后这个音调就会引发恐惧。
And they were working on that. And indeed, in phase one of their experiments, dogs were put into a havoc and given Pavlovian conditioning with shock. But they were running into this enormous problem is they wanted to see the next day when dogs were put in a different situation, a shuttle box in which the dogs just needed to run from one side to the other to turn off shock that the dogs didn't run. So in some ways, what you observed was that on day one, the dogs were essentially learning to associate the painful electric shock with this tone, but they could do not. nothing about it. They couldn't escape. On day two, the dogs were placed in a position where they
他们正在研究这个。事实上，在他们实验的第一阶段，狗被放入一个装置中，并接受巴甫洛夫条件反射的电击。但他们遇到了一个巨大的问题，他们想看看第二天当狗被放入不同的环境——一个穿梭箱，狗只需要从一边跑到另一边就能关掉电击——时，狗却不跑。所以从某种程度上说，你观察到的是，第一天，狗基本上学会了将痛苦的电击与这个音调联系起来，但它们对此无能为力。它们无法逃脱。第二天，狗被放置在一个位置，它们
were hearing these tones and they could escape, but in fact they were not doing so. And this was a puzzle for the people in your lab. You interpreted this in some ways as the dogs experiencing helplessness? I said, you know, there's something much more important in Pavlovian conditioning than learning the association of a tone with shock. The dogs are helpless. In Pavlovian conditioning by definition, there's nothing you can do about it. The shock comes regardless of what you do, and their interest was, did you learn to be afraid of the tone? But could it be that more important to an animal or person is the fact that you're helpless in this situation, and that you might be learning that nothing you do matters?
听到了这些音调，它们本可以逃脱，但实际上它们并没有这样做。这对你实验室的人来说是一个谜。你从某种程度上将其解释为狗体验到了无助感？我说：“你知道，在巴甫洛夫条件反射中，比学习音调与电击的联系更重要的事情是，狗是无助的。”根据定义，在巴甫洛夫条件反射中，你对此无能为力。无论你做什么，电击都会发生。他们的兴趣在于：你是否学会了害怕这个音调？但有没有可能，对动物或人来说更重要的是，你在这种情况下是无助的，而且你可能正在学习到你所做的一切都无关紧要？
And if that were so, it would make sense that the next day, when you got shock again, you just lay there and didn't do anything. So this began a major uphill battle between me and the behaviorists. And what was behind it was the notion that people and animals were cognitive, that they could think, that they could integrate experience. across time. And we theorized that the animals has learned that nothing they did mattered. I understand that a psychologist named Donald Hiroto extended some of this work with a very interesting experiment involving human beings. Describe for me what Heroto did, Marty. Yeah, so Don Herodo said, let's try exactly the same thing with humans. So what Don did, and it became an entire field, he put for day one headphones on people and turned on a loud,
如果是这样，那么第二天当你再次受到电击时，你只是躺在那里什么也不做，这就说得通了。于是，我和行为主义者之间开始了一场重大的艰苦斗争。其背后的观念是，人和动物是有认知能力的，他们可以思考，他们可以整合跨时间的经验。我们推测，动物已经学会了它们所做的一切都无关紧要。我了解到一位名叫唐纳德·希罗托的心理学家通过一个涉及人类的非常有趣的实验扩展了这项工作。马蒂，请为我描述一下希罗托做了什么。
annoying noise. This is the equivalent of shock, nothing traumatic, but very annoying. And for one group, nothing you did matter. For a second group, you got the tone, but you could press a button to turn off the noise. And then the next day, Don built a human shuttle box. About four feet long, you put your hand on one side, and noise went on. And all you had to do was move your hand to the other side of the shuttle box. And lo and behold, he found that the people who had had the helplessness experience, inescapable noise, just something. And so, sat there with their hand in the shuttle box and didn't move. And that was the beginning of a vibrant field of learned helplessness, which went way beyond the animal laboratory to the
是的，所以唐·希罗托说：“让我们在人类身上尝试完全相同的事情。”所以唐所做的——这成为了一个完整的领域——他在第一天给人们戴上耳机，并打开一个响亮的、
question of human trauma and human depression. So you used this term learned helplessness a moment ago, and it's an important term to stop and ponder for a second. How would you describe the phenomenon of learned helplessness, Marty. What is it? Here are the basics of learned helplessness. First, the event is inescapable, the first event. Nothing you can do matters. And what we believed was that people learned that nothing they did mattered.
恼人的噪音。这相当于电击，不是什么创伤性的，但非常恼人。对于一组人来说，你做什么都无关紧要。对于第二组人，你听到了音调，但你可以按一个按钮来关掉噪音。然后第二天，唐建造了一个人类穿梭箱。大约四英尺长，你把手放在一边，噪音就会响起。你所要做的就是把手移到穿梭箱的另一边。结果发现，那些有过无助体验、经历过无法逃避的噪音的人，只是……坐在那里，手放在穿梭箱里，没有移动。这就是“习得性无助”这一充满活力的领域的开端，它远远超出了动物实验室，延伸到了
And this had two consequences. The first consequence is you became passive later on, particularly when you faced a similar kind of annoying or traumatic event. And the second problem was that you had a lot of trouble learning that you could do something about it. So once you had learned that nothing you did mattered, it was very hard to unlearn it. But the most surprising thing we found, Chunker, was there was an emotional consequence as well, that people felt sad and anxious. So there was passivity, cognitive difficulty, and emotional sadness and anxiety.
人类创伤和人类抑郁的问题。你刚才用了“习得性无助”这个词，这是一个值得停下来思考的重要术语。马蒂，你会如何描述习得性无助的现象？它是什么？习得性无助的基本原理如下。首先，事件是无法逃避的，即第一个事件。你所做的一切都无关紧要。我们认为，人们学会了他们所做的一切都无关紧要。
Importantly, this was not the result of trauma itself. We controlled for that. It was a result of not having any control over trauma. And so that was the operative variable that in many ways has been the arc of my entire life's work. And of course, you can think about so many groups of people who experience something like this in the real world. If you're a small child, for instance, your life is governed by people who are bigger than you, more powerful than you. And if they treat you badly, you might not have options to escape your circumstances. If you're trapped in poverty, for example, you might not have the ability to escape your circumstances.
这产生了两个后果。第一个后果是你在后来变得被动，特别是在面对类似恼人或创伤性的事件时。第二个问题是，你很难学会你可以对此采取行动。所以一旦你学会了你所做的一切都无关紧要，就很难忘记它。但我们发现最令人惊讶的事情是，尚卡尔，它还有情感上的后果，人们感到悲伤和焦虑。所以存在被动性、认知困难以及情感上的悲伤和焦虑。
And you can quickly see how these experiments in the lab might have much, much bigger consequences in the real world. Exactly. And so I thought a great deal about poverty, about war, and in particular, adult circumstances in which you're helpless. And there was a literature that I got very interested in about sudden death itself. I remember interviewing someone named Harold Kushner, who had just come back from being a prisoner of war in Hanoi. And Harold told me the story of his best friend, Robert. They were down to about 95 pounds by then. But they kept Robert going by telling them that he was first on. on the list to be released, and that in December he was going to be released, particularly if he
重要的是，这并不是创伤本身的结果。我们对此进行了控制。这是因为对创伤没有任何控制权的结果。所以这就是那个起作用的变量，在许多方面，它构成了我毕生工作的核心。当然，你可以想到现实世界中许多经历过类似情况的人群。例如，如果你是一个小孩，你的生活由比你大、比你强大的人支配。如果他们虐待你，你可能没有选择来逃避你的环境。例如，如果你陷入贫困，你可能没有能力逃避你的环境。
cooperated and told them about what he did during the war. Well, December first came around, and he wasn't released. And Harold told me, Robert just shriveled up, and within a few days, was dead. So I was not only interested in early experiences of abuse, helplessness, systematic experiences like poverty, but adult experiences in which, even though you've had a lifetime of doing well and you're deprived of control, what the consequences were. I understand that at one point, Marty, you spotted a connection between what you were seeing with learned helplessness and the pervasive phenomenon of depression. Talk about that connection that you made.
你可以很快看出这些实验室实验在现实世界中可能会产生大得多的后果。正是如此。所以我对贫困、战争，特别是成年人感到无助的情况进行了大量思考。我记得采访过一位名叫哈罗德·库什纳的人，他刚从河内的战俘营回来。哈罗德给我讲了他最好的朋友罗伯特的故事。那时他们体重已经降到了大约95磅。但他们通过告诉罗伯特他是第一个被释放名单上的人，并且在十二月他将被释放，特别是如果他
When I was a graduate student, one of my young professor was someone named Jim Gier. And Jim came up to look at the helpless dogs. And he looked at them and said, Marty, that's depression. I said, what's depression, Jim? And now, if we go back to 1970, depression was not a category. So if you looked at the diagnostic categories, there was something called manic depression. But by 1975, the Diagnostic and Statistical Manual of the American Psychiatric Association for the first time isolated a new disorder called unipolar depression.
配合并告诉他们他在战争期间做了什么，来维持罗伯特的生存。好吧，十二月一日到了，他没有被释放。哈罗德告诉我，罗伯特一下子就萎靡了，几天之内就死了。所以我不仅对早期的虐待、无助、像贫困这样的系统性经历感兴趣，而且对成年人的经历也感兴趣，即使你一生都做得很好，但你被剥夺了控制权，后果会是什么。马蒂，我了解到在某个时候，你发现了你在习得性无助中看到的现象与普遍的抑郁症现象之间的联系。谈谈你所做的那个联系。
Unipolar depression had nine different symptoms, and if five of them were present for two weeks or more, you got the diagnosis. So the symptoms were passivity, cognitive difficulty, sadness, anxiety, trouble sleeping, food, not tasting, good, numbness, lack of mirth, and thoughts of death. So, I looked at those nine symptoms, and then I looked at the very large literature I learned helplessness, which had accumulated by 1975. Eight of the nine symptoms were present. The only one that wasn't present in the laboratory,
当我还是研究生时，我的一位年轻教授名叫吉姆·吉尔。吉姆来看那些无助的狗。他看着它们说：“马蒂，那是抑郁症。”我说：“吉姆，什么是抑郁症？”现在，如果我们回到1970年，抑郁症还不是一个类别。所以如果你查看诊断类别，有一种东西叫躁郁症。但到了1975年，美国精神医学学会的《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》首次分离出一种名为“单相抑郁症”的新疾病。
was thought to death. And that's probably because we're using things like loud noise. And so I proposed that learned helplessness was a model of depression. And indeed, that went on to become the leading model of depression. And it led to a vibrant neuroscience in which people tried out drugs that broke up helplessness in the laboratory in rats, for example, and then tried them in people. And it turned out the drugs that worked to break up helplessness of the laboratory became the leading antidepressants. Now, the research that you were conducting at this time was focused on the people who experienced adverse conditions. They became helpless and then perhaps even depressed. But there was also another.
单相抑郁症有九种不同的症状，如果其中五种持续两周或更长时间，你就会被诊断出来。这些症状是：被动性、认知困难、悲伤、焦虑、睡眠障碍、食物没味道、麻木、缺乏快乐感以及死亡念头。所以，我看了那九种症状，然后看了到1975年为止积累的关于习得性无助的大量文献。九种症状中有八种都存在。唯一一个在实验室里没有出现的，
group of subjects that at first you didn't pay so much attention to. Tell me about this group of subjects, Marty. Who were they? And what did you notice? In the entire helplessness literature, both in animals and people, the helplessness effect was statistical. So when I described a person becoming passive and just sitting in the shuttle box and not doing anything, that was five out of eight people on average or a helpless rat that five out of eight of them were helpless. But about a third were not. And so starting in the 1970s, I began to ask, well, what is it about some people, some animals that made them resilient or resistant to helplessness? What is it about some people that make you in spite of the fact that your girlfriend has rejected you, your stocks have
是死亡念头。那可能是因为我们使用的是像响亮噪音这样的东西。所以我提出习得性无助是抑郁症的一种模型。事实上，它后来成为了抑郁症的主导模型。它引领了一场充满活力的神经科学研究，人们尝试了在实验室中能打破大鼠无助感的药物，例如，然后尝试在人身上使用。结果证明，在实验室中能打破无助感的药物成为了领先的抗抑郁药。现在，你当时进行的研究集中在那些经历过不利条件的人身上。他们变得无助，甚至可能抑郁。但还有另一组，
gone down, what is it that gives some people the courage to transcend helplessness? And this was the turning point in my career. So you started thinking about what might distinguish the people who become helpless and passive in the face of adversity from those who remain motivated. and energetic, were there differences between the groups and in the stories they told about their experiences, Marty? Yes, and it led to nailing down what it was about the one-third of people who didn't become helpless. Optimism versus pessimism. These were vague terms to me at the time,
起初你并没有太关注。马蒂，告诉我关于这组受试者的事。他们是谁？你注意到了什么？在整个无助感文献中，无论是在动物还是人身上，无助感效应都是统计学上的。所以当我描述一个人变得被动，只是坐在穿梭箱里什么也不做时，那是平均八个人中的五个，或者一只无助的老鼠，八只中有五只是无助的。但大约三分之一不是。所以从20世纪70年代开始，我开始问：“嗯，有些人、有些动物身上有什么特质使他们具有韧性或对无助感有抵抗力？”是什么让一些人在尽管女朋友拒绝了你、你的股票下跌的情况下，
but what we wondered was when you have a bad example, a traumatic experience, you could believe there's nothing I can do and I'm helpless. But we postulated from the stories we heard that what protected people from helplessness, what made them resilient was different dimensions of interpreting what happens to you when bad events occur. So first, you might believe that the bad event was going to last forever. Or you might believe it was temporary. And so, for example, if you fail in examination, you might say, I had a hangover.
依然有勇气超越无助感？这是我职业生涯的转折点。所以你开始思考是什么区分了面对逆境变得无助和被动的人与那些保持动力和活力的人，马蒂，这些群体之间以及他们讲述自己经历的故事之间有什么不同吗？是的，这导致了确定那三分之一没有变得无助的人的特质。乐观与悲观。在当时，这些对我来说是模糊的术语，
That's temporary. That means the next time you confront an examination, you'll be fine. On the other hand, you might say to yourself, I'm stupid. That's permanent. So the first thing we thought about was when bad events occurred to you Shankar, do you reflexively believe they're going to last forever? Or do you believe no? Just this one time. The second dimension we worried about was pervasive versus local. And that is, you're rejected by your girlfriend. You could believe I'm unlovable. Well, unlovable is pervasive, and it means no matter who you come across, you're not going to find love. On the other hand, you might say, that's her. And we postulated that people who believed that helplessness was pervasive would go on to generalize across situations. People who believed it was temporary, would recover quickly. So we began to look at the way people interpreted the bad events in their
但我们想知道的是，当你有一个糟糕的例子、一次创伤性经历时，你可能会认为“我无能为力，我很无助”。但我们从听到的故事中推测，保护人们免受无助感、使他们具有韧性的是解释发生在你身上的坏事时的不同维度。首先，你可能认为坏事会永远持续下去。或者你可能认为它是暂时的。例如，如果你考试不及格，你可能会说：“我宿醉了。”
lives. And this opened up an enormous literature on learned optimism. And it basically showed that the people who became helpless in the laboratory believed the helplessness was permanent, pervasive, and typically their fault. The third of people who didn't become helpless believed it was temporary, it was just this one situation, and it wasn't their fault. So having established the importance of explanatory styles, Marty, you began to generate evidence that an optimistic or pessimistic explanatory style can significantly affect how people go about pursuing goals.
那是暂时的。这意味着下次你面对考试时，你会没事的。另一方面，你可能会对自己说：“我很笨。”那是永久的。所以我们想到的第一件事是，当坏事发生在你身上时，尚卡尔，你会下意识地认为它们会永远持续下去吗？还是你会认为：“不，只是这一次。”我们担心的第二个维度是普遍性与局部性。也就是说，你被女朋友拒绝了。你可能会认为“我不可爱”。嗯，不可爱是普遍的，这意味着无论你遇到谁，你都不会找到爱。另一方面，你可能会说：“那是她的问题。”我们推测，认为无助感是普遍的人会将其推广到各种情况。认为它是暂时的人会很快恢复。所以我们开始观察人们解释生活中坏事的方式，
One place you explored this was at the West Point Military Academy. Paint a picture for me of that study. So we not only asked the question about depression. So what we did was to take large groups of people at time one, measure their explanatory style, and then go on to predict who's going to become depressed. And it turned out the pessimists, the people who believed, it's me, it's going to last forever, are between two and eight times as likely to become depressed.
这开启了关于“习得性乐观”的大量文献。它基本上表明，在实验室中变得无助的人认为无助感是永久的、普遍的，而且通常是他们的错。那三分之一没有变得无助的人认为它是暂时的，只是这一种情况，而且不是他们的错。马蒂，在确立了解释风格的重要性后，你开始产生证据，证明乐观或悲观的解释风格会显著影响人们追求目标的方式。
And so we then asked the question, let's test this in the real world. And so one thing we did is we went to West Point. And West Point at the time, and still does to some extent, had something called Beast Barracks. Well, West Point is one of the most selective schools in the United States. These are very highly qualified young men and women. But in the first six weeks, in mid-summer, July, they arrive at West Point, and they're put through six weeks of helplessness
你探索的一个地方是西点军校。请为我描绘一下那项研究。所以我们不仅问了关于抑郁症的问题。我们所做的是在时间点1选取大量人群，测量他们的解释风格，然后去预测谁会变得抑郁。结果证明，悲观主义者，即那些认为“是我造成的，它会永远持续下去”的人，变得抑郁的可能性是其他人的两到八倍。
experience in which the attempt is explicitly to break them. They're woken up at foreign the morning, sent on a 10-mile run, they're systematically abused. And my memory is that about a third of the candidates drop out. So we asked the question, could you predict from day one in Beast Barracks who was going to drop out? And it turned out it was the pessimists who dropped out. We then looked at something very similar about the grades you get in college. We looked at the optimists and the pessimists, and we asked who does much better than their talent augurs, and it was the optimists, and who does much worse, and it was the pessimist. And then in selling insurance, exactly the same thing.
所以我们接着问了一个问题，让我们在现实世界中测试一下。我们做的一件事是去了西点军校。西点军校当时——现在在某种程度上仍然如此——有一种叫做“野兽营”的东西。嗯，西点军校是美国最挑剔的学校之一。这些都是素质极高的年轻人。但在最初的六周，在仲夏的七月，他们到达西点军校，并经历了六周的无助
I had been working on learned helplessness and optimism in Olympic swimming. And I'd just come back from a day of looking at our Olympic swimming data. And the phone was ringing. I picked up the phone and it was an insurance salesman. And I hung up on him. And I said to myself, gee, this must be an awfully difficult job. I mean, people hanging up on you all the time. And it so happened that the month before, I had become friendly from a professional meeting with the CEO of Metropolitan Life.
体验，其目的明确是要击垮他们。他们凌晨四点被叫醒，去跑10英里，他们受到系统性的虐待。我的记忆是大约三分之一的候选人退出了。所以我们问了一个问题：你能从“野兽营”的第一天就预测出谁会退出吗？结果证明，退出的是悲观主义者。我们随后观察了大学成绩中非常相似的情况。我们观察了乐观主义者和悲观主义者，我们问谁的表现远超他们的天赋所预示的，结果是乐观主义者；谁的表现远差于预期，结果是悲观主义者。然后在销售保险方面，完全一样。
And I had told him about optimism and pessimism. And I said, well, Marty, if you ever have an application to life insurance, give me a call. So I called him up. And I said, well, how do you hire life insurance sales? said, well, there's an SAT of life insurance, recommendations, do you want to make a lot of money? And we hire 5,000 new salesmen a year because of this. But after one year, 50% of them drop out. And after four years, 90% of them have quit.
我一直在研究奥林匹克游泳中的习得性无助和乐观主义。我刚从查看我们的奥林匹克游泳数据的一天回来。电话响了。我接起电话，是一个保险推销员。我挂断了他的电话。我对自己说：“天哪，这一定是一份非常困难的工作。我是说，人们总是挂断你的电话。”碰巧的是，前一个月，我在一次专业会议上与大都会人寿的首席执行官成为了朋友。
They just can't take the rejection. said, well, I think I've got a test that might predict who can stick with a difficult job like life insurance. We've just found out it predicts grade point average and it predicts Olympic swimming success. Maybe it'll predict professional success. So indeed, Metropolitan Life started to give the test. First, they found that the pessimistic life insurance salesman is more optimistic than you or me. You have to be frank, instidiously optimistic to even start. And then they hired a special force of 140 salespeople who knocked the top off of optimism scale.
我告诉过他关于乐观和悲观的事情。我说：“嗯，马蒂，如果你有任何关于人寿保险的申请，给我打电话。”所以我给他打了电话。我说：“嗯，你们是怎么招聘人寿保险销售员的？”他说：“嗯，有人寿保险的SAT考试、推荐信，你想赚很多钱吗？因为这个，我们每年招聘5000名新销售员。但一年后，50%的人退出了。四年后，90%的人辞职了。”
This special force outsold everyone at MetLife, and by the end of four years, 75%, as opposed to 10%, were still working. So we basically found across success in beast barracks, grade point average, and difficult jobs that the optimists did better than the pessimists. And they were the people who didn't become helpless in the laboratory. Most of us think our lives are shaped by events. But just as important is the meaning we assign to those events. The way we interpret a setback today can quietly influence the decisions we make tomorrow and the future we ultimately create. When we come back, we'll explore one of the most powerful forces in human psychology.
他们就是受不了拒绝。我说：“嗯，我想我有一个测试，可能能预测谁能坚持像人寿保险这样困难的工作。我们刚刚发现它能预测平均绩点，也能预测奥林匹克游泳的成功。也许它能预测职业成功。”所以大都会人寿确实开始进行这项测试。首先，他们发现悲观的保险推销员比你或我更乐观。你必须坦率地说，甚至要极其乐观才能开始。然后他们雇佣了一支由140名销售人员组成的特别部队，他们的乐观程度处于顶端。
The belief that our choices can shape. what happens next. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Has this conversation evoked your own experiences of feeling helpless? Or has it reminded you of a time when you stepped up and took charge of your own destiny? If you have a personal story you'd be willing to share with a hidden brain audience
这支特别部队的销售额超过了大都会人寿的所有人，四年结束时，75%的人仍在工作，而普通组只有10%。所以我们基本上发现，在“野兽营”的成功、平均绩点和困难工作中，乐观主义者的表现都优于悲观主义者。他们就是那些在实验室里没有变得无助的人。我们大多数人认为我们的生活是由事件塑造的。但同样重要的是我们赋予这些事件的意义。我们今天解释挫折的方式可以悄悄地影响我们明天做出的决定以及我们最终创造的未来。回来后，我们将探索人类心理中最强大的力量之一。
or a question or comment about the science of optimism and pessimism, please find a very quiet room and record a voice. memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty. Email the file to us at feedback at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, how to make a difference. Again, that's feedback at hiddenbrain.org. Martin Seligman is a psychologist at the University of Pennsylvania. He's the author of many books, including most recently, Agency, the psychological history of human progress. Marty, so much of this conversation has really been about whether people feel like they can make a difference in their own lives. It's about the idea of agency. How do you define that term?
相信我们的选择可以塑造接下来发生的事情。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这次谈话是否唤起了你对无助感的个人经历？或者它是否让你想起你挺身而出、掌控自己命运的时刻？如果你有一个愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享的个人故事，
Agency is the opposite of learned helplessness. If you break it down, it's got three beliefs. The first is efficacy, and that's the belief that in the here and now, you can accomplish a specific goal. The second was optimism. And that's the belief that you can accomplish this goal, not just now, but into the future and into the far future. And the third is imagination, which is the range of possible goals that you might achieve. And the broader the range of goals, the more agency. So full-blown agency is efficacy. I can do it in the here and now.
或者关于乐观和悲观科学的问题或评论，请找一个非常安静的房间，在手机上录制一段语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。将文件通过电子邮件发送给我们：feedback@hiddenbrain.org。使用主题行“如何做出改变”。再次强调，是feedback@hiddenbrain.org。马丁·塞利格曼是宾夕法尼亚大学的心理学家。他是许多书的作者，包括最近的《代理：人类进步的心理学历史》。马蒂，这次谈话的很大一部分实际上是关于人们是否觉得他们能在自己的生活中做出改变。这是关于“代理”的概念。你如何定义这个术语？
Optimism. I can do it in the future. And imagination. I can innovate across many different situations. So this idea of agency is something that fascinates you, and you think that it tells us the story of humankind. How so, Marty? My hypothesis was that because,
代理是习得性无助的对立面。如果你把它分解开来，它有三个信念。第一个是效能感，即相信在此时此地，你可以完成一个特定的目标。第二个是乐观主义。即相信你可以完成这个目标，不仅是现在，而且是在未来，甚至是在遥远的未来。第三是想象力，即你可能实现的各种目标。目标范围越广，代理能力就越强。所以成熟的代理能力是效能感：我可以在此时此地做到；
because agency is such a potent force that maybe this was the psychological state that was key to progress and innovation. Let me take you through some of the main highlights, which convinced me of this. One of the great mysteries of human history, it's called the mystery of the Axial Age. So come back with me to 1,000 BCE. What you've got is primitive societies, small villages. This is true of Greece. It's true of the Hebrews. It's true of China.
乐观主义：我可以在未来做到；以及想象力：我可以在许多不同的情况下进行创新。所以这个代理的概念让你着迷，你认为它讲述了人类的故事。马蒂，怎么说？我的假设是，因为，
It's true of India. It's true of Persia. A thousand years BCE. 500 years BCE, all of these societies, have changed radically. The Buddha has lived, Confucius has lived, Socrates has lived, and progress breaks out. Technology, medicine, arts, literature, the first smattering of political freedom. What happened between 1,500 BCE? I think I've discovered the answer. And that is, and that is humans discover the concept of agency.
因为代理是一种如此强大的力量，也许这就是进步和创新的关键心理状态。让我带你了解一些让我确信这一点的主要亮点。人类历史上最大的谜团之一，被称为“轴心时代之谜”。所以回到公元前1000年。你拥有的是原始社会、小村庄。希腊如此，希伯来人如此，中国如此，
So the hypothesis I had was that maybe in a thousand BCE, they didn't have the words for agency, words like, I can do it, human agency and the like. And there's an entire lexicon of agency, which I had created. So in Homer, for example, in the, Aalid, Achilles doesn't decide to act. Athena tells Achilles to act. But a hundred years later, in the Odyssey, you've got Odysseus, who's this clever, cunning, wily person.
印度如此，波斯如此。公元前1000年。公元前500年，所有这些社会都发生了根本性的变化。佛陀生活过，孔子生活过，苏格拉底生活过，进步爆发了。技术、医学、艺术、文学，政治自由的最初萌芽。公元前1500年之间发生了什么？我想我已经发现了答案。那就是，人类发现了代理的概念。
The gods have started to leave the stage. And so convincingly, across these cultures, by 500 BC, E, and so, convincingly, You've got a massive vocabulary of human agency, and you can track it almost century by century. So I took the entire Old Testament and looked for agentic verbs and words. And grossly you can see that the Torah is God commanding and humans obeying, with a few exceptions, like choose life. But as you go into the prophets and the writings, human agentic words occur more, divine agentic words occur less. And now it turns out you can have AI read the entire Old Testament, book by book, and rate how agentic each book is. And you plot it across time and it's linear.
所以我有的假设是，也许在公元前1000年，他们还没有代理的词汇，比如“我可以做到”、“人类代理”之类的词。我创造了一个完整的代理词汇表。例如在荷马的《伊利亚特》中，阿喀琉斯并没有决定行动。雅典娜告诉阿喀琉斯去行动。但一百年后，在《奥德赛》中，你有了奥德修斯，他是一个聪明、狡猾、机智的人。
So as time goes on from the Torah to essentially 300 BC, the Babylonian exile, more and more agency occurs. And if you plot it against human innovation, population, standard of living, political freedom, technology, it's linearly related to the development of the words. I mean, in some ways, the point that you're making, Mardi, is that there was a time when, when people essentially turn their fates over to the gods, where they assume that the gods were telling them what to do, that their fates were written on their foreheads, if you will. And over time, people started to feel, no, in fact, it's not the gods, but I, the individual who actually can do things.
神已经开始离开舞台了。因此，令人信服的是，在这些文化中，到公元前500年，你拥有了大量的人类代理词汇，你可以几乎按世纪追踪它。所以我拿了整本《旧约》，寻找代理动词和词汇。你可以粗略地看到，《托拉》是上帝命令，人类服从，只有少数例外，比如“选择生命”。但当你进入先知书和著作时，人类代理词汇出现得更多，神圣代理词汇出现得更少。现在事实证明，你可以让AI逐书阅读整本《旧约》，并评估每本书的代理程度。你把它绘制在时间轴上，它是线性的。
And your argument really is that the more people have come to feel like they themselves can be the architects of their future, the more, in fact, that future has shown signs of flourishing, signs of innovation and progress. Exactly so. Two comments on it. Progress in agency have not been linearly going up in human history. And when does progress stagnate? When does the human condition deteriorate? And the Christian Middle Ages are a very interesting example of that. And this is not what you were taught in school. But basically, early, Christianity is highly agentic and highly optimistic, and then something radical happens. In actually 383 AD, and it's St. Augustine. St. Augustine says grace is arbitrarily bestowed by God. predestination occurs and there is no human will that is independent of arbitrary grace.
所以随着时间的推移，从《托拉》到公元前300年左右的巴比伦之囚，出现了越来越多的代理。如果你把它与人类创新、人口、生活水平、政治自由、技术进行对比，它与词汇的发展是线性相关的。我的意思是，从某种程度上说，马蒂，你提出的观点是，曾经有一段时间，人们基本上把命运交给了神，他们假设神在告诉他们该做什么，如果可以的话，他们的命运写在额头上。随着时间的推移，人们开始觉得：“不，事实上，不是神，而是我，这个个体，实际上可以做事情。”
This becomes the theology of the Middle Ages. And if you plot progress across time, basically the Middle Ages believe that God does it and humans don't do it. And it's not until the Renaissance that Augustine's views are overthrown and progress breaks out. So that's one point. When does stagnation occur? But the other has to do with China versus the West and the importance of agency in China. Western agency, Shankar, is about I can do it. the individual, and indeed progress in the West, is intimately related to I can do it.
你的论点确实是，人们越是觉得他们自己可以成为未来的建筑师，那个未来就越显示出繁荣、创新和进步的迹象。正是如此。对此有两点评论。进步和代理在人类历史上并不是线性上升的。进步何时停滞？人类状况何时恶化？基督教中世纪就是一个非常有趣的例子。这不是你在学校里学到的。但基本上，早期基督教具有高度的代理性和高度的乐观主义，然后发生了一些激进的事情。实际上是在公元383年，是圣奥古斯丁。圣奥古斯丁说恩典是上帝任意赋予的，预定论发生了，没有独立于任意恩典之外的人类意志。
But we've asked exactly the same question about the history of China. But in the history of China, we quantify we agency as well as I agency. And to make a long story short, the balance in China between we agency and I agency is what predicts population, innovation, GDP, and the like. And when we agency in the form of the state is very high and crushes individual agency, that's when you get stagnation and regression. But when there's a balance between collective agency and individual agency in China, that's when progress breaks out. A reminder, has this conversation evoked your own experiences of feeling helpless? Or has it reminded you of a time when you stepped up and took charge of your own destiny? If you have a personal story you'd be willing to share with the hidden brain audience
这成为了中世纪的神学。如果你绘制跨时间的进步，基本上中世纪认为上帝做了这一切，而人类没有做。直到文艺复兴时期，奥古斯丁的观点被推翻，进步才爆发。所以这是一点。停滞何时发生？但另一点与中国和西方有关，以及代理在中国的重要性。尚卡尔，西方的代理是关于“我可以做到”，即个体，事实上西方的进步与“我可以做到”密切相关。但我们对中国历史也问了完全相同的问题。但在中国历史中，我们量化了“我们代理”以及“我代理”。长话短说，中国“我们代理”与“我代理”之间的平衡是预测人口、创新、GDP等的因素。当以国家形式出现的“我们代理”非常高并压制个体代理时，那就是停滞和倒退的时候。但当中国集体代理与个体代理之间存在平衡时，那就是进步爆发的时候。提醒一下，这次谈话是否唤起了你对无助感的个人经历？或者它是否让你想起你挺身而出、掌控自己命运的时刻？如果你有一个愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享的个人故事
or a question or comment about the science of optimism and pessimism, please find a very quiet room and record a voice. memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty. Then email the file to us at feedback at hiddenbrain.org using the subject line, how to make a difference. Again, that's feedback at hiddenbrain.org. In our episode next week, we take a deep dive into the ingredients and drivers of agency. We examine how people can become more agentic and how you can help the people around you discover their autonomy, drive, and self-confidence. Mardi told me how he himself has taken his research to heart and learned to be more optimistic and agentic, and, as he puts it, less of a grouch.
或者关于乐观与悲观科学的问题或评论，请找一个非常安静的房间，在手机上录一段语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。然后将文件通过电子邮件发送给我们，地址是feedback@hiddenbrain.org，邮件主题请注明“如何做出改变”。再说一遍，地址是feedback@hiddenbrain.org。在下周的节目中，我们将深入探讨能动性的要素和驱动力。我们将研究人们如何变得更具能动性，以及你如何帮助周围的人发现他们的自主性、动力和自信。马蒂告诉我，他自己是如何将他的研究铭记在心，并学会变得更加乐观和具有能动性，用他的话来说，就是不再那么爱发牢骚了。
I think it's important to tell you about it, Chonker. I'm sitting in the garden. I'm a gardener with my five-year-old daughter, Nikki. We're weeding together. I am grimly. I am grimly. pulling weeds out, Nikki's having a wonderful time. She's dancing and singing, throwing weeds in the air, running around, and I shouted at her. Nikki, get to work. And Nikki walks away from me, come back and says, Daddy, can I talk to you? He said, yeah, what is it, Nikki? And Daddy, do you remember that before my fifth birthday, I was a whiner that I whined all the time? I said, yeah, Nikki, you were pretty horrible. And Nikki said, well, that was two weeks ago, my birthday.
我想告诉你这件事，尚卡尔。我当时正坐在花园里。我是一个园丁，和我五岁的女儿尼基在一起。我们正在一起除草。我当时很严肃，非常严肃地在拔草，而尼基却玩得很开心。她又跳又唱，把杂草扔向空中，跑来跑去，我冲她喊道：“尼基，快干活。”尼基走开了，又回来对我说：“爸爸，我能跟你谈谈吗？”我说：“好啊，怎么了，尼基？”“爸爸，你还记得在我五岁生日之前，我是一个爱抱怨的孩子，我总是抱怨个不停吗？”我说：“记得，尼基，你那时候确实挺糟糕的。”尼基说：“嗯，那是两周前，在我生日之前。”
And have you noticed that I haven't whined once in the last two weeks? Oh, yeah, yeah, you've been a real pleasure. Well, Daddy, on my fifth birthday, I decided I wasn't going to whine anymore. And that was the hardest thing I've ever done. And if I can stop whining, you can stop being such a grouch. Well, this was for me an epiphany, and it changed my career. In that moment, Shankar, I realized that I was a grouch, and indeed I was proud of being a grouch. What a grouch does, he sees everything wrong with what's going on, criticizes it, and corrects it.
“那你有没有注意到，过去两周我一次都没有抱怨过？”“哦，是的，是的，你确实表现得非常好。”“嗯，爸爸，在我五岁生日那天，我决定不再抱怨了。那是我做过的最难的事情。如果我能停止抱怨，你也能停止做一个爱发牢骚的人。”嗯，这对我来说是一个顿悟，它改变了我的职业生涯。那一刻，尚卡尔，我意识到我是一个爱发牢骚的人，而且我确实为自己是一个爱发牢骚的人感到自豪。爱发牢骚的人会看到正在发生的事情中所有不对劲的地方，批评它，并纠正它。
And it occurred to me for the first time in my life that maybe any success I had had in life was not because I was a grouch. but in spite of it. And so I resolved to personally change. And by the way, I do measure these things, shocker, and I'm a completely different person than I was 30 years ago. I'm not a grouch anymore. Martin Seligman is a psychologist at the University of Pennsylvania.
我人生中第一次意识到，也许我一生中取得的任何成功，并不是因为我爱发牢骚，而是尽管我爱发牢骚才取得的。因此，我下定决心要从个人层面做出改变。顺便说一句，我确实会衡量这些事情，尚卡尔，我与30年前相比已经完全是另一个人了。我不再是一个爱发牢骚的人了。马丁·塞利格曼是宾夕法尼亚大学的心理学家。
He's the author of Agency, the Psychological History of Human Progress. Marty, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. I've been enjoying our time together, This is great fun for me, Shankar. I hope it's fun for you. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul,
他是《能动性：人类进步的心理学历史》一书的作者。马蒂，非常感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》节目。我很享受我们在一起的时光，这对我来说非常有趣，尚卡尔。希望你也觉得有趣。《隐藏的大脑》由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·保罗、
Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Before we go, I'd like to give a special shout-out to a friend of mine who has a new podcast. I first met Vivek Murthy years ago when he joined me as a friend. a guest on Hidden Brain. At the time, Vivek was the Surgeon General of the United States, and he was particularly interested in calling attention to the issue of loneliness and social isolation.
克里斯汀·黄、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。在结束之前，我想特别向我的一位朋友致意，他有一个新的播客。我多年前第一次见到维韦克·穆尔蒂时，他作为嘉宾参加了《隐藏的大脑》。当时，维韦克是美国卫生局局长，他特别关注孤独和社会孤立的问题。
His episode with us was hugely popular, in large part because Vivek has a powerful way of showing vulnerability and talking about topics that can be painful to discuss. Vivek has continued to expand on his work on social connection in the year since our interview, and I'm delighted to recommend his new show. It's called Staying Human, and if you love Hidden Brain, I'm confident that you love staying human as well. You can find it wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他参与的那期节目非常受欢迎，很大程度上是因为维韦克有一种强大的方式来展现脆弱，并谈论那些可能令人痛苦的话题。在我们采访后的几年里，维韦克继续扩展他在社会联系方面的工作，我很高兴推荐他的新节目。它叫《保持人性》，如果你喜欢《隐藏的大脑》，我相信你也会喜欢《保持人性》。你可以在任何获取播客的地方找到它。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。再见。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。